[Aplausos]
[Música]
argentina es el líder mundial en
exportación de psicoanalistas en este
país el fútbol el tango y las crisis
económicas son prácticamente una
tradición nacional pero esto podría
cambiar mucho antes de lo que nos
podríamos imaginar si amigos de visual
política otra vez más os estoy hablando
del litio el material con el que se
fabrican las baterías de nuestros
teléfonos móviles las de vuestros
ordenadores portátiles y las de los
coches eléctricos
[Música]
como ya os decía en este otro vídeo
argentina es junto con chile y bolivia
uno de los tres países que conforman el
llamado triángulo del litio la zona del
mundo donde se concentra entre el 60 y
el 80 por ciento de las reservas que hay
de este mineral sin embargo de estos
tres países argentinas es el que más
atención internacional ha logrado
acaparar todos esos grandes fondos de
inversión tienen los ojos puestos en el
país
[Música]
sí sí habéis oído bien argentina ese
país que hace pocos años tenía las
peores calificaciones crediticias es
ahora la niña bonita de las principales
empresas mineras del planeta así que la
pregunta es de verdad judía argentina
liderar la carrera por el litio que han
hecho en este país para mejorar su
imagen en el exterior en qué medida
puede el litio convertir a argentina en
el nuevo abu dhabi hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
los argentinos primero durante las
últimas décadas argentinas se había
convertido en algo así como el hombre
del saco de los inversores
internacionales
a los extranjeros que obtienen ganancias
también son terroristas económicos del
pecado de la especulación
los que lleváis mucho tiempo suscritos a
visual político ya sabéis que el
gobierno de cristina fernández de
kirchner hizo todo lo posible para
ahuyentar a cualquier empresario que
quisiera invertir en el país en el
sector minero y petrolero
kirchner tampoco se quedó atrás en 2008
sacó una ley contra la repatriación de
capitales
[Música]
es decir que si una empresa minera
australiana por ejemplo hacía beneficios
explotando petróleo o minerales en suelo
argentino el gobierno le prohibía que
enviara ese dinero de vuelta a australia
el objetivo de kirchner era obligar a
esos inversores extranjeros a gastar el
máximo dinero posible dentro del país
pero las consecuencias fueron que la
mayor parte de los empresarios dejaron
de pensar en argentina como un lugar
donde invertir a fin de cuentas para que
iban a hacerlo si no podían quedarse con
los beneficios sin embargo el auténtico
punto de inflexión vino en el año 2012
argentina ex propia repsol su filial y
pf para los que no conozcáis la historia
repsol es una compañía petrolera
española que se fusionó con otra empresa
argentina que se llamaba y pf en el año
1998 durante muchos años a esta nueva
empresa se la conocía como repsol y pf
pero un buen día cristina fernández de
kirchner al más puro estilo donald trump
dijo eso de que los argentinos primero
hashtag make argentina great again que
las empresas que están aquí
accionistas sean extranjeros las
empresas radicadas aquí son empresas
argentinas y os preguntaréis qué sucedió
después por supuesto se dieron montones
de peleas legales entre repsol y el
gobierno de argentina pero eso no es lo
peor de todo el mayor problema es que
está y pf que ahora estaba nacionalizada
bajo su producción de petróleo a la
mitad
[Música]
la producción de petróleo argentina
continúa en declive por la ralentización
de la actividad de las plataformas de
perforación y os preguntaréis qué tiene
que ver el hecho de que una empresa sea
pública o privada para que produzca más
o menos barriles de petróleo
por supuesto que hay muchas petroleras
públicas que funcionan muy bien ahí
tenemos el ejemplo de aramco que aunque
pertenece al gobierno de arabia saudita
produce más barriles de zumo de
dinosaurio que ninguna otra compañía
privada en el planeta el problema es que
tanto el mundo del petróleo como el
mundo de la minería requieren de
muchísima tecnología y normalmente cada
empresa tiene sus propias patentes
dicho de otra forma cuando ipc quiere
explotar los yacimientos de vaca muerta
necesita utilizar una tecnología muy
especial que se llama el fracking de la
que ya os hemos hablado en otros vídeos
y solamente hay unas poquitas empresas
que tienen las máquinas necesarias para
poder realizar este tipo de procesos por
eso es tan común que en un yacimiento
nos encontremos a dos empresas
colaborando y cooperando juntas
cuando se fue repsol la petrolera
argentina perdió a un socio tecnológico
y eso explica que años después de que
kirchner se enfrentará a esos malvados
neoliberales españoles terminar
asociándose con los estadounidenses
[Música]
chevron firmó un acuerdo de 1.500
millones de dólares con ypf pero esto
tampoco es lo peor de todo el problema
de expropiar una empresa de la noche a
la mañana es que al resto de empresarios
se les quitan las ganas de invertir en
tu país pensando bien imaginad que
tenéis vosotros una empresa minera
realmente gastar y aix vuestro dinero en
construir plantas y fábricas en un país
cuyo gobierno os las puede expropiar sin
previo aviso muy probablemente no y eso
entre otros muchos factores es lo que
explica que argentina hoy en día está en
una de sus peores crisis económicas sin
embargo con la llegada al poder de
mauricio macri las cosas están cambiando
[Música]
fiebre del oro blanco en argentina en
diciembre de 2015
mauricio macri llega a la casa rosada la
casa rosada es algo así como la casa
blanca pero versión argentino por eso
les digo y gracias
[Aplausos]
con un país en bancarrota con una
inflación no oficial que superaba el 40
por ciento y donde ninguna empresa
estaba dispuesta a invertir y todo esto
pese a ser uno de los países con más
recursos naturales del mundo por eso
desde el minuto cero de su presidencia
macri se ha dedicado a dar un giro de
180 grados a todo lo que había hecho su
predecesor
el nuevo gobierno de argentina elimina
los impuestos especiales a la minería en
otras palabras
macri sabe que el litio es una
grandísima oportunidad para que
argentina pueda cuadrar sus cuentas
públicas por supuesto que nadie espera
que de la noche a la mañana argentina
vaya a convertirse en el nuevo dubai
pero este oro blanco es como un dinero
caído del cielo que argentina le vendría
muy bien para poder tapar sus agujeros
financieros sin tener que subir los
impuestos ni hacer recortes de gasto y
eso explica leyes como esta
[Música]
argentina cierra un acuerdo sobre
minería para unificar todas las
legislaciones y atraer a los inversores
además a diferencia de lo que ocurría
durante los años de kirchner las
empresas extranjeras pueden hacer lo que
quieran con los beneficios que obtengan
y esto ocurre porque macri ha anulado la
famosa ley que prohibía la repatriación
de beneficios
pesos pesados de la industria como
albemarle corporation sociedad química y
minera de chile eramet o si andy están
entre los grupos que quieren expandir o
construir nuevas explotaciones de litio
en argentina
pero esperad un momento porque no todo
es tan bonito por supuesto que el litio
es una gran oportunidad para argentina
pero ya sabéis que tener recursos
naturales es muy distinto de ser rico y
muchos argentinos tienen miedo de
convertirse en el nuevo potosí es decir
que durante muchos años las empresas
extranjeras llegan al país se lleven los
recursos y apenas dejen dinero en la
economía argentina así que la pregunta
es qué podría hacer argentinas para
evitar este potencial desastre
[Música]
la verdadera oportunidad de argentina
como decíamos en el anterior vídeo el
verdadero negocio del litio no está en
extraer el metal y venderlo fuera sino
en fabricar objetos de alto valor
añadido como baterías
para que os hagáis una idea mientras
hacemos este vídeo la tonelada métrica
de litio cotiza en el mercado por unos
9000 dólares si esa tonelada de litio la
convertimos en baterías de teléfono
móvil podríamos ingresar entre un millón
y medio o cinco millones de dólares por
supuesto que es un cálculo muy
aproximado pero nos permite entender la
diferencia entre vender materias primas
o bienes industriales pero esperad un
momento porque no todo es tan sencillo
casi todas las fábricas de baterías de
litio están en lugares como eeuu
alemania o por supuesto china en estos
tres países existe un enorme tejido
industrial con toda una red de empresas
pequeñitas que proveen de materiales y
servicios a las grandes
hablamos de logística semiconductores
etcétera el hecho hace que la
fabricación sea más rápida y más barata
pero no sólo eso
este efecto red también sirve para
atraer a los mejores ingenieros y
profesionales especializados que son
imprescindibles para poder montar una
fábrica de alta tecnología
y como consigues convencer a una chica
que a lo mejor está trabajando en san
francisco cobrando 100 mil dólares al
año para que se venga a rosario a
trabajar en una fábrica como os podéis
imaginar es bastante complicado
así que os preguntaréis qué puede hacer
macri para industrializar su país lo
primero que tenemos que tener en cuenta
es que silicon valley no se creó en dos
tardes sin embargo argentina cuenta con
una ventaja que por ejemplo no tenia
california y esa ventaja es que ahora
pueden hacer dinero rápido con la venta
de litio ese dinero no sólo es una
oportunidad para que el gobierno de
argentina pueda cuadrar sus cuentas
es también un colchón que se puede
utilizar para crear universidades tan
necesarias para formar a los
profesionales que podrían crear esas
pequeñas empresas tan necesarias para
poder suplir de materiales y de recursos
a las grandes fábricas de baterías en
otros vídeos hemos explicado por ejemplo
cómo israel llegó a convertirse en una
meca tecnológica gracias entre otras
cosas a proyectos de cooperación entre
el estado y las empresas privadas y en
principio parece que macri está decidido
a ir en esa dirección
hemos aprendido que además de nuestro
talento y nuestros enormes recursos
naturales tenemos que añadir constancia
a estado de derecho y predictabilidad
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque también
hay muchos nubarrones todas estas
oportunidades que tiene argentinas se
irían a pique sin macri o quien le
suceda intenta volver al
internacionalismo y espantar a los
extranjeros y por lo que parece cristina
fernández de kirchner quiere volver a
presentarse a las elecciones yo no
estamos pidiendo ni que me voten a mí
y que voten a los que están un poco más
atrás mío no no no no estamos pidiendo
que se voten a ustedes mismos en defensa
de ustedes mismos
así que la pregunta es podría argentina
recuperar esa seguridad jurídica y
hacerse rico gracias al litio o
volveremos a ver otra crisis económica
en este país
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y por supuesto no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros al canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]
i